these are the virus vigilantes dressed
in plastic Macs and makeshift protective
gear and a taking control of health
monitoring in Hong Kong themselves
they're nearby residents and political
activists living closest to one of the
border crossings with mainland China and
they're desperately worried about the
virus on their doorstep so they're
screaming everyone entering this border
town here all the passengers coming off
the bus have come from mainland China so
everyone's a suspected host of the
deadly coronavirus and not all of them
are happy with this unofficial health
check although we don't want to frighten
them but the virus is spreading our
neighborhood so I think it is a
necessary force most of them the
tourists from the China that's why we
want to measure their body temperature
to make sure there's no any any fever if
they're favored we will ask the police
for help our undercover reporter in
mainland China filmed increased
precautions at the Shenzhen Bay port
crossing into Hong Kong passengers have
to fill out health forms and are asked
if they feel unwell or they've come from
the epicentre most points into Hong Kong
have been closed down but there are
still thousands using the crossings
still open and that includes the
International Airport
on the Hong Kong side there are some
attempts to disinfect the buses but they
seem quite cursory many of the
passengers who are returning from Lunar
New Year's celebrations on the mainland
seem unaware the viruses believed to
stick to hard surfaces like handles
doors and seats and can remain active
for up to 72 hours standing room only
basically and their crossing from the
mainland every 15 minutes and every one
of these people could be a carrier of
the coronavirus most want the border
sealed entirely but only after they're
over prepared they Coast then the Hong
Kong people yes but do you feel that
maybe you could be part of the risk I
mean you could maybe be bringing the
virus back as well
I do worry about that yeah yes will you
be taking extra precautions
so no no it's
not much
but anyway so what I do Hong Kong's
first coronavirus death was a 39 year
old man who went to hospital the day he
returned from the Wuhan epicentre but in
that short time it seems he infected his
mother who didn't go to the mainland but
who he lived with in these flats in Hong
Kong the city's health officials now
fear there's a corona virus outbreak in
Hong Kong they just don't know how
serious or widespread it is but at least
four of those suffering were almost
certainly infected inside the city the
alarming developments have spurred
thousands of health workers to step up
their strike accusing the city's chief
executive of putting Beijing's demands
ahead of Hong Kong's safety this is a
very critical moment I think is you need
to do some special measurement or
special intervention to prevent that the
virus comes to Hong Kong everyone may be
a potential risk to facing I think that
we have the responsibility to stay now
and to to do what we think is right in
the front line may be the protective
equipment is not enough and very tight
support the surpriser it fight the
spread of the virus in one of the most
densely populated developed cities is a
frightening specter and health experts
are warning the next two weeks will be
critical Alex Crawford Sky News Hong
Kong